five Christmas treats that are more
sinful than you perhaps care to know no
Christmas market in Germany is complete
without mulled wine it's made from a dry
red wine pieces of orange and spices
like cinnamon aniseed and cloves with or
without rum steaming into fifth place is
mulled wine at about 210 calories a
glass it'll warm you up give you a bit
more holiday cheer and some extra
insulation around the hips over 80
million Germans put away some 40 million
litres of it every year another holiday
specialty is thick and heavy even before
it's even takers need leavened dough add
lots of butter candied lemon peel
candied orange peel and raisins rolling
into fourth place of our sinful German
holiday treats is dread they're stolen
at a hefty 400 calories 400 grams that's
195 calories per slice it's been whipped
up in Dresden since 1474 and is sold on
the streets unmarked and elsewhere about
1/4 of all stolen baked goes abroad it's
fruitcake when a personal handler the
stolen made it
Nuremberg is hometown to a specialty
both filling and fattening it has been
for more than 500 years marching into
third place is Nuremberg gingerbread
whether chocolate iced or glazed both
back a 420 calorie punch 400 grams but
at least they're nice and spicy with
aniseed nutmeg ginger and cloves
these are one of every Christmas market
goers favorite things in bright copper
kettles almonds are caramelized with
brown sugar and come out as roasted
almonds the sweet kind in our ranking
they tumble straight into second place
with over 500 calories 400 grams but the
irresistible aroma of freshly roasted
and sweetened almonds on the Christmas
market can swiftly obliterate any factor
figure this gentleman may be a saint but
he's also a temptation to sin Santa
Claus dropping into first place among
our Christmas treats that you might not
have known were so sinful is the
chocolate Santa He bestows a generous
536 calories 400 grams
that'll stuff more than your stockings
Germans have been eating this guy for
nearly 200 years now there are even sexy
santa clauses for added incentive
[Music]